Simone says for the footer can I just
call the display contact function and
append it to the footer,
although the header already displays
the same contact information?
Yes you'll probably need a slightly
different function just because you're,
well or it could be this, it depends
on how you define it but if you write
something that adds the information in
the same way, just to a different div,
then sure, give that a shot,
reuse your code, that's great.
It is true that it's just repeating
the same information, but
that's just to sort of remind you at
the end that, by the way, here I am,
now that you finished
looking at my resume,
here's my contact information again,
thanks a lot.
Comment really from Simone
who says believe it or not,
I actually really like the colors
on the resume as it is,
would you recommend that
I change it anyway?
No, if you love it you don't have to.
Thank you for saying that you like it.
We'll have to pass that
on to the designers so
don't feel like you have to change it.
But maybe for practice you might,
you might do it.
With data.otherfunction, function
declaration, I'll switch back over.
Do you still need the var other
function statement or is it okay,
is the data period other function
equal function statement sufficient?
Do you need var in that?
>> When you're adding a function
to an existing object, so,
in this case we have data,
which is our object, and
then we added this function called
other function to data down here.
And we we went through that.
You actually don't need var in this
case because all we're doing is
adding something to
something that exists.
And because data had already
existed we're just adding to it and
not creating a new function or
a new variable or anything like that.
And because of that,
you actually don't need to use var.
>> So she's asking in project two,
do we have to put all the info that is
named your education image
into resumeBuilder.js.file?
Does that mean that we do not do
any in line text in the html file?
So the html file is, yeah,
I don't think you have to in
line anything in the html file.
Everything that you work on
is on the JavaScript file,
so I think it's best practice
to sort of just do all your
processing and rendering the data
within JavaScript functions,
and then calling those functions
within your html file.
>> Yeah.
>> Everything, all the information
about your resume, all the information,
everything goes into your
resumeBuilder.js.file.
>> Michelle Cry says,
how do you make a resume interactive
when they usually contain a static view?
>> Okay, yeah that's a great question.
[CROSSTALK]
>> Good question.
>> So, in our instance,
we're actually adding the sort of
interactive component with map.
>> Yeah.
>> So
it's either going to be a map of where
you either worked or gone to school and
it'll be very similar to like a Google
map, any sort of map you see online.
Now that will sort of be the interactive
element that we're requiring.
But just sort of in general I mean,
you can take a look at, search for
resumes online of web developers or go
to any sort of web developer website and
their resume is usually on there.
And there's some interactive elements.
Sometimes it's just as simple
as the navigation menu bar
moving in a certain way, or disappearing
as you scroll down the page.
Or it could be as crazy as
something like parts of the resume
come flying into the page or there's
a background photo and the background
photo changes as you scroll through
the resume and stuff like that.
I've seen a lot of really interesting
and creative ones out there.
There's really no limit what you can do,
it's kind of like being an art student.
You're limited by how much you're
willing to put into the project.
>> I found a lot of JavaScript
codes online that I want to use.
Can I copy it and use it as long as I
understand it and can fully explain it?
Absolutely.
>> Yeah.
I mean that's 90 percent of what
a lot of web developers do.
I think, is they go online they
read code, they reuse code.
Gosh, I don't know where I would
be if I didn't have the internet.
>> Yeah, I would still be stuck
trying to learn CSS right now.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I would be like,
how do I flush out a box?
Do I need to look up the book?
No.
This one good thing about web
development, everything is open.
>> Right.
You can look at, if you find a cool
site or you found something really cool,
local function, you just open up
your code and see what did they do.
>> Yeah.
>> Now it's like, as long as you
attribute that code, making sure that,
okay, I just commented on it or
I found this little code here,
this little snippet, this is what it is.
People will usually find what that is.
>> Yeah, that's what I usually do,
too, is when I find, a piece of
code online and I'm like, this
pretty much knows what I want to do.
And I don't want to fight it too much.
I always leave a little comment and
I put the url in the comments.
>> Exactly.
>> Cite the person just like you would
if you're writing an essay, right?
>> Yeah.
>> You mark it,
you put it in the footer.
And that way if I'm looking, going
back and looking through my code and
I'm looking at, how did I figure
this out, where did I get this from?
It gives me a chance to go back and
look at, yeah, that's right,
this person did this.
And on top of that it also kind of gets
me to kind of look at the other things
that maybe that person has done too, and
it sort of opens my eyes to some other
ways of solving some different
problems I may not have thought about.
So it's a great way, I mean, looking for
ways that people have done certain
things online is a great way to learn.
An easy way to do this, I mean,
is just to go to any website.
And if you see something that is
really fascinating like I said,
maybe there's some moving part and
you're like, woah, how did they do that?
You can usually go,
look at the dev tools,
look at the source code for the page and
kind of figure out what they did there
and try to mimic that on your site.
It's a really fun learning
experience doing that.
The one thing I will say though is if
you do you use something, make sure
it's stylistically good like it's under
the style guide that we're providing.